An actor with style and delivery can elevate
the form — and the human spirit — with
their performance, but at the end of the day,
it's also a profession.
Although a role in a critically acclaimed
indie flick might earn a few pats on the back
and awards, at the end of the day, it's usually
blockbusters that pay the bills.
These actors have been guilty of taking gigs
strictly for the money — but to their credit,
they were totally upfront about it afterward.
Sir Michael Caine in Jaws: The Revenge
Sir Michael Caine is one of the most acclaimed
actors in modern cinema.
His six-decade filmography is laced with award-winning
performances, including his roles in Woody
Allen's Hannah and Her Sisters, as well as
several nominations for Alfie and The Quiet
American.
Naturally, not every performance can be a
winner and not every film is destined to be
met with critical acclaim — and like the
rest of us, Mr. Caine still needs to eat.
Hence the actor's participation in fare such
as Jaws: The Revenge, the fourth and final
movie in the Jaws franchise.
The knighted thespian is unapologetic for
his presence in the movie — which scored
an embarrassing 14 percent audience review
on Rotten Tomatoes — and his famously candid
quote sums things up perfectly.
"I have never seen it, but by all accounts
it is terrible.
However, I have seen the house that it built,
and it is terrific."
Sir Alec Guinness in Star Wars: A New Hope
For the younger members of the cast, 1977's
original Star Wars: A New Hope was a springboard
to a film career.
But for their veteran counterparts, the space
opera was just another job.
Take Alec Guinness, for example.
Already the Academy Award-winning star of
renowned films like Doctor Zhivago and Lawrence
of Arabia, Guinness — who plays Jedi Knight
Obi-Wan Kenobi in the original trilogy — was
reportedly nonplussed with his newfound Star
Wars stardom.
His autobiography includes his recollection
of a moment when he discouraged an overzealous
fan from watching the films again, and he
clearly saw the part as a paycheck in numerous
interviews.
"And then when I opened it and found it was
science fiction I thought, 'Oh crumbs, this
is simply not for me.'"
While on set he also wrote to longtime friend
Anne Kauffman, "I just think, thankfully,
of the lovely bread, which will help me keep
going until next April."
The force was strong with his wallet.
Jackie Chan in Rush Hour
Since Jackie Chan's "official" Western audience
debut in 1995's Rumble in the Bronx, Chan
has remained a consistent presence on the
American cultural landscape, even enjoying
a stint as an animated character in Jackie
Chan Adventures.
In the late '90s, though, seeking to further
his global influence and crossover appeal,
Chan teamed up with Chris Tucker for the Brett
Ratner-directed action-comedy flick Rush Hour.
It proved an undeniable box office darling,
spinning off several sequels, but later, Chan
admitted his own distaste for the goofball
movie.
"I have reasons to do each film, I have something
to say.
Unlike Rush Hour—there was no reason [in
making it], you just give me the money and
I'm fine.
I dislike Rush Hour the most, but ironically
it sold really well in the U.S. and Europe."
"Do you understand the words that are coming
out from my mouth?
"Nobody understands the words coming out of
your mouth, man!"
Well, ain't that a kick in the chops.
Glenn Close in Guardians of the Galaxy
Glenn Close's talent speaks for itself, but
in today's film industry, the bulk of the
films in development are would-be tentpoles,
and prestige pictures are few and far between.
It's left actors like Close, who appeared
in Marvel's first Guardians of the Galaxy
movie, to subsidize their art through sometimes
surprising means.
"I just did two independent films this summer
and I had an absolute ball with fantastic
actors, but in August, I'm gonna go off and
do the next generation of Marvel Comics/Disney
and I get to be the chief police of the galaxy.
I'm doing that because it will then afford
me to go do the other kind of movies that
I really love."
Sadly, under the circumstances, her mercenary
attitude makes sense.
So moviegoers can certainly forgive Ms. Close
for her fiscally based rationale.
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar in Airplane
Whatever happened to Kareem Abdul-Jabbar's
movie career?
Sure, he wasn't about to win any Oscars, but
he was pretty solid for a basketball star
turned actor.
His Airplane! role, as the copilot Roger Murdock
marked the beginning of a post-NBA acting
and voicework career.
"We have clearance, Clarence"
"Roger Roger.
What's our vector, Victor?"
Abdul-Jabbar's motives to branch out into
acting may not have been artistically pure,
but he did have a natural charisma that, in
addition to his colossal height, made him
stand out.
Airplane! co-directors David and Jerry Zucker
said they offered Abdul-Jabbar a cool sum
of $30,000 for the role — and the hoopster's
manager got back to them with a very "creative"
reason for a slight hike in rate.
"The agent asked for $35,000 because that's
how much this rug cost that Kareem wanted
to buy."
"...our initial reaction was, 'That's got
to be the best line we've ever heard from
an agent.'"
"But then a couple of weeks later, there's
an article in Time with a picture of Kareem
standing in front of the oriental rug that
he'd bought for $35,000 after we'd paid him."
At least Abdul-Jabbar was up-front about his
reel requirements.
Betsy Palmer in Friday the 13th
One of the big gotcha moments in the horror
blockbuster Friday the 13th is the climactic
reveal that Jason isn't the murderer, but
rather, it's his mother played by Betsy Palmer.
For the killer role, director Sean Cunningham
recruited TV vet Betsy Palmer, whose credits
include Studio One in Hollywood and Love American
Style.
Apparently, the opportunity came at the perfect
time, as Palmer told MovieWeb.
"The phone rang and my agent said, 'How would
you like to do a movie?' and I said, 'Great!
That will pay for the car I want to buy.'
And I said, 'Oh… nobody is ever going to
see this.'"
Boy, that sure backfired on her — the movie's
visibility, that is.
Hopefully not the car.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!